bonjour je m'appelle Roberta j'ai 20 ans
et je recherche un emploi en tant que
vendeuse en prê àorte je viens de
Saint-André je recherche dans le secteur
nord et nord-est j'ai eu mon beep et bac
professionnel prospection négociation et
fidélisation avec mention au lycée
jean-pierin Saint-André j'ai fait de
nombreux stages mais celui qui m'a plus
marqué c'est avec les bénisteries
vananatachz l'homme de Saint-André avec
eux j'ai fait des salons de la maison
qui a qui m'a vraiment ouvert les portes
au niveau du métier de la vente j'ai
commencé par des simples stages avec eux
mais au fur et à mesure ils ont vu ma
capacité et mon ambition au niveau
professionnel donc j'ai pu déboucher
vers un CDD avec eux et là vraiment ça
m'a ouvert vraiment les portes du métier
durant ma période de formation j'ai
acquéri en expérience j'ai gagné en
confiance en moi aussi j'ai beaucoup
appris sur les personnes qui venaient
pour demander un conseil ou pour être
orienté j'ai appris à être sociable
envers les personnes je suis une
personne motivée ambitieuse et je pense
généreuse sur le terrain j'adore
conseiller aider et orienté je crois que
je vous ai tout dit sur moi maintenant
vous avez les cartes en main et je suis
prête dès maintenant à travailler donc
je n'attends qu'une seule chose que vous
me contactez